[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire l'islamo gauchisme le nom
est désormais partout forgé par pierre
andré taguieff en 2002 repris par manuel
valls et marine le pen
popularisée par jean michel blanquer
après l'assassinât de samuel pâtit il a
suffi que frédéric vidal la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur demande une
enquête sur le sujet à l'université pour
que le ciel lui tombe immédiatement sur
la tête
aucune réalité scientifique café du
commerce slogan partisans lui ont
répondu les plus hautes instances
universitaires
le président de la république et son
premier ministre se sont vite
désolidarisé de la pauvre ministre
gabriel attal le porte-parole du
gouvernement a dû rappeler que la
liberté académique existe encore en
france etc les chercheurs sont
indépendants seuls gérard darmanin bien
voulu lui se porter à son secours
alors l'islamo gauchisme existe-t-il
s'agit-il d'une véritable menace ou d'un
simple délire d'une inquiétude légitime
ou d'une chasse aux sorcières pour
débattre nous avons invité sami ben
ieseau ni doctorant en philosophie à
l'école normale supérieure chargée de
cours en finance de marché à l'essec
vous êtes l'auteur avec anne-sophie
nogaret de français malgré eux ces
sous-titrés racialiste des colonialistes
indigéniste une enquête sur ce qu'ils
veulent déconstruire la france ce cher
l'artilleur alors ça me comment est ce
que vous avez comment vous analysé cette
polémique
bonsoir frédéric taddeï alors en
quelques mots ce que traduit cette
polémique c'est une extrême crispation
autour de la thématique alors crispation
à la fois sémantique on l'a vu et je
j'imagine qu'on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir amplement lors de cette émission
mais aussi aux crispations conceptuel
voire politique
on sent toute la difficulté d'un pays à
débattre d'un certain nombre de
questions qui sont pourtant relativement
essentielle et c'est ce que ces derniers
ces dernières semaines ont montré au
tour de la polémique vidal kaoutar
harchi vous êtes sociologue chercheur
associé au service le centre de
recherche sur les ciels les liens
sociaux de l'université paris descartes
êtes l'auteur de je n'ai qu'une langue
ce n'est pas la mienne qui était paru
chez fayard
vous voulez vous la voyez comment cette
polémique
cette polémique comme la manifestation
supplémentaire du racisme qui traverse
les élites françaises et qui traverse
aussi les structures étatiques
ce n'est pas étonnant finalement qu'une
fin supplémentaires ce soir les
questions qui ont a trait aux conditions
de vie matérielle et sociale et
symbolique des populations issues de
l'immigration post coloniale qui soit me
suis mis à l'index donc une
manifestation du racisme comme on en
connaît depuis des décennies voire plus
dans ce pays à la poly car vous vous
êtes politologue vous avez enseigné à la
faculté de droit et de sciences
économiques de limoges chercheur associé
au cevipof de sciences po vous êtes
auteur de l'inquiétante familiarité de
la race soit en sous-titré des
colonialismes intéressés à terre
sectional ite et universalisme c'est
paru aux éditions du bord de l'eau vous
vous l'analysez comment cette polémique
avec beaucoup d'inquiétude parce que il
me semble que c'est une stratégie que
mène une partie la société et notamment
ce gouvernement pour créer un ennemi de
l'intérieur qui doit faire alliance avec
des ennemis de l'extérieur qui sont
généralement des populations non
blanches et il me semble que on a là une
stratégie à la trump une stratégie
emprunté à la pride qui consiste à
opposer des populations qui ont des
divergences certainement sur leur mode
de vie mais qui ne sont pas
fondamentales et de rejouer la grande
scène de l'assimilation c'est à dire
l'idée que certaines populations disons
le musulmane ne serait pas assimilables
donc je vois ça avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'inquiétudes et je pense que
frédéric vidal mérite absolument une
sanction et cette sanction là comme je
lé réclamer avec un grand nombre
d'intellectuels dans dans le monde de
cette sanction la de peut-être que la
démission elle a perdu toute la
confiance de la communauté universitaire
julien talpin vous êtes chargé de
recherches en sciences politiques au
cnrs et codirecteur du gx démocratie et
participation et vous faites partie des
auteurs de l'ouvragé collectif l'épreuve
de la discrimination qui vient de
paraître aux presses universitaires de
france vous voulez analyser comment
cette polémique
bonsoir je crois que cette polémique
traduit la profonde méconnaissance du
monde universitaire de la part de de la
ministre est une forme aussi deux
dentiers intellectualisme qui témoignent
au fond de la distance du gouvernement
et des intellectuels et en particulier
des sciences sociales et je crois que ça
témoigne également du de la colonisation
au fond des as du monde de la recherche
par des enjeux politiques et très
clairement la volonté de la part de
gouvernements de à d'occuper le terrain
de l'extrême droite dans la préparation
du duel macron le pen de 2022
et voilà je compatis de ça aujourd'hui
alors commençons d'ailleurs par la
querelle sémantique vous y faisiez
allusion sami biasini l'expression
islamo gauchiste
elle rappelle à certains le
la chasse aux sorcières des années 30
concernant les judéo bolchévique ou le
complot judéo maçonnique
comment le comment réagissez vous à ceux
qui vous dit ça alors je pense que la
manière est plus simple de répondre à
cette question des essais de d'en
référer à l'un de ses promoteurs qui est
pierre andré taguieff pierre andré
taguieff effectivement à celui qui a
popularisé et celui qui a popularisé le
terme en 2002 ce qu'il explique dans ce
mot-valise islam au gauchisme c'est
qu'il ne s'agit pas de l'islamo pour
l'islam mais probablement d'un mot
valise mal formés il s'agirait en
réalité d'islamisme au gauchisme
c'est-à-dire dans sa définition d'une
forme de complaisance d'une partie de la
gauche et de pas de toute la gauche
on retrouve là ce terme de gauchisme
employés par lénine 1 c'était 7,7
maladie du communisme et donc c'est en
ce sens qu'il faut l'entendre c'est à
dire c'est une forme de compromis d'une
partie de la gauche qui est ce qu'une
partie très politisé très engagé
présente et il a on pense que c'est un
point important
certes sur certains campus mais en
réalité dans la société c'est ce que la
ministre vidal a essayé de dire
probablement très maladroitement en tout
cas de manière très audible vis-à-vis du
de la portion politique de l'islam voire
je dirais même pour être plus précis
javi d'un islam and l'islamisme radical
extrémistes et non pas et n'ont pas dû
de l'islam en général en tout cas c'est
la manière dont pierre andré taguieff
relate les choses et ça me semble assez
recevable kaoutar harchi dans les souris
le nom de pierre andré taguieff soit
cité comme si de rien n'était alors
qu'aujourd'hui
marion maréchal-le pen a repris et un
entretien de tendre et pierre andré
taguieff pour souligner son accord avec
lui non plus à l'est du mans je crois
qu'il est important de revenir aux
fondements delà de la problématique à
sarah l'idée selon laquelle il
existerait une sorte de gauche qui a
tout d'un coup a troqué le peuple
ouvrier nationale contre un autre peuple
qui serait le peuple le peuple immigré
et on ne
vous donnerai pas à cette gauche
finalement d'avoir fait le choix d
étrangler alors qu'elle aurait dû faire
le choix des pauvres de l'intérieur on
voit ici nié toute là tout un pesanteur
des discours extrémistes de droite
je voudrais souligner aussi pays
historiquement cette notion de l'islamo
gauchisme quand même beaucoup circulé
aussi dans des milieux de gauche avec
toute la problématique du caractère
trans partisan de l'islamophobie
donc il me semble assez assez important
de dire que derrière cette notion
d'islamologie sma chaque fois qu'elle
qu'elle se manifeste et à chaque fois
finalement qu'on accole ont un nom un
adjectif un syntagme à l'expression
d'yves terme aux recherches généralement
à entamer des processus de
disqualification des processus dit
légitimation des manières finalement de
dire à des gens qui sont présents sur le
territoire national français depuis de
très longues années et pour des raisons
très précises qui n'ont rien à faire ici
et qu'il vaudrait mieux qu'ils partent
donc on voit ici se réactiver à travers
cette notion distingue au schisme comme
je le disais au départ une forme de
racisme latent qui traverse une grande
partie des institutions françaises qui
est notamment répercutée par les médias
mais aussi par par le monde politique
donc cette notion elle est véritablement
à concevoir comme une injure à caractère
raciste
vous êtes d'accord alain politique a
grossièrement absolument oui oui bon je
dirais simplement que c'est insignifiant
flottant reste à mogo schiste n'a pas
toujours eu le même sens alors vous
faites remonter ça a attaqué c'est vrai
il a utilisé dans la nouvelle vidéo
phobie en 2002 dans à l'époque où il
était chef et dentistes et où il n'était
pas encore celui que a juste dit tout
stigmatisant pour certain nombre d'entre
nous en tout cas
mais il remonte à plus loin en réalité
le premier usage c'est arman un
spécialiste de
deux mouvements ouvriers qui était un
trotskiste nous devons ouvrir
britannique qui était lui même trop de
christ et qui avait écrit un livre
s'appelle le prophète et le prolétariat
en 94 et à ce moment-là il envisagé mais
pas forcément de façon toujours à
probati ve la possibilité d'une alliance
entre l'islamisme définit d'ailleurs
assez différemment de la façon dont nous
entendons aujourd'hui et et puis là
l'ultra gauche entre ou l'extrême gauche
7 cette alliance le titre encore une
fois dû livrer le prophète et le
prolétariat autrement dit c'était l'idée
qu'il pouvait y avoir comme ça a déjà
été dit il ya un instant il peut y avoir
dans la danse chez les musulmans une
possibilité de trouver un nouveau
prolétariat capable de faire alliance
donc et de renverser l'ordre établi
puisqu'il des trotskistes maintenant il
était aussi extrêmement anti-religieux
d'ailleurs pas illogique en tentant de
pister
il était assez critique par rapport à la
façon dont l'islamiste puisse comporter
là où il pouvait avoir le pouvoir
ceci étant évidemment il ne parlait pas
d'islamisme au sens de terrorisme nous
nous en parlons aujourd'hui et le mot
islamo-gauchiste il avait un doublement
à défaut fondamental on va y en a
beaucoup mais à défaut fondamental c'est
que quand on sait pas si on parle de
l'islam si on parle de l'islamisme et le
problème est que précisément chez ceux
qui l'utilisent il ya la volonté de
confusion c'est à dire au fond de dire
qu'un musulman est potentiellement un
islamiste et l islamiste ne sait au fond
à djiddah distincts 1a terroristes et
c'est ce que blanc caire disait au fond
en attaquant les intellectuels
responsables d'eux des voiliers en
quelque sorte leur leurs fonctions en se
faisant les propagandistes d'une
idéologie totalement grande qui
gangrènent l'université le mot de
gangrène a été repris d'ailleurs par
vidal qui à l'époque d'ailleurs quand
blanc qu'elle avait utilisé le premier
avait voulu défendre l'honneur
universités elle a un peu oublié ce
qu'était universités aujourd'hui je
viens tu alpin
oui je crois que c'est un outil qui sert
d'abord à à disqualifier c'est comme le
disait notre collègue philippe marlière
un mot ramon matraque au fond elle a
raison c'est qu'ils ciblent utile
initialement chez tag est sa cible est
principalement des militants d'extrême
gauche autour de mouvements
altermondialistes et a été ciblé
derrière cela une alliance possible qu
avait commencé à voir le jour au moment
du forum social européen en 2003 entre
certaine frange de militants contre
l'islamophobie est et l'extrême gauche
le drame me semble-t-il aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on mélange tout effectivement
comme le disait à la polka
c'est à dire que je ne vois pas de
partis ou de mouvements de gauche qui
serait laxiste complaisant avec le
terrorisme djihadiste ou avec
l'islamisme revanche il y a une petite
fraction mais qui demeure font très
minoritaire de la gauche française qui
commence à prendre le parti de la lutte
contre l'islamophobie
ce qui n'a rien à voir au fond avec
l'islamisme ou au terrorisme on pourrait
même considérer que la meilleure façon
de lutter contre le terrorisme c'est au
fond de luttes et enfin sérieusement
contre l'islamophobie qui gangrène notre
notre société on voit bien ici qu'on est
très loin en fait du milieu
universitaire et on a eu une sorte de
translation au départ d'un seul mot qui
sert à disqualifier une partie de la
gauche vers le monde universitaire qui
ont assez peu à voir avec avait avec ces
débats là puisque désormais ce sont les
études postcoloniales les gens qui
travaillent sur les questions à ciral y
compris les gens qui travaillent sur les
enjeux intersectionnelle où les
questions de genre qui seraient ciblés
par ce mot et on voit bien que le flou
explique c'est la notion mais ne renvoie
à rien de sérieux comme d'ailleurs l'a
rappelé le cnrs en soulignant que ça n'a
aucune réalité scientifique
alors effectivement à l'université
ce qui est visé quand on emploie le
terme islamo gauchistes comme l'a
utilisé frédéric vidal ce sont les
toutes les études sur les
discriminations aussi bien les études
des colonials que les études
intersectionnelle
alors au fond que leur reproche-t-on à
ses études
en quoi serait telle idéologiquement
problématique
sami bellini et bien sony alors en fait
alors je ne sais pas si les deux sont
problématiques je pense que déjà 2 en
premier lieu il faut dissocier alors
c'est mal compris dans le débat les
études postcoloniales
du reste les études postcoloniales sur
une discipline de l'université et
frédéric vidal elle même je ne suis pas
là pour faire la défense de frédéric
vidal prendre la défense de frédéric
vidal mais le rétablir la vérité de ces
propos prédit que ces études avaient
leur place dans l'université les études
postcoloniales
ce sont l'ensemble des études qui ont
visé en fait c'est assez anciens avaient
dans leurs formes modernes le terme et
ayant été popularisée en 1989 mais en
réalité c'est une sont antérieurs à star
au moment de la décolonisation à penser
au travers du regard de celui qui
n'avaient pas la parole
autrefois c'est à dire le colonisé à
penser sa propre histoire et à penser
l'histoire du monde et cette discipline
aujourd'hui je pense est une discipline
qui a fait ses preuves et qui tout à
fait recevable
simplement ce que vise ou viserait je
pense la ministre lorsque l amalgame le
terme d'extrême gauche estime que je
n'emploie pas moi-même pour
effectivement ces raisons de 2,2 de
complexité et de police et mis un peu un
peu difficile finalement à imposer ce
qu'est la scala malghem en fait c'est le
des colonialismes c'est-à-dire un
mouvement politique une démarche plus
politique dans des colonialismes il ya
une forme de performativité le des
privatives dire ce qu'il veut dire c'est
à dire que il vise à défaire le joug
symbolique ou réelle de la colonisation
auprès de ceux qui en seraient victimes
et surprend frantz fanon et je sais
qu'on à d'éminents experts de frantz
fanon autour de cette table virtuelle
on sait depuis france panon que ou avec
frantz fanon qu'il y aurait une forme de
permanence
de la fonction coloniale ou des
représentations coloniale à la fois chez
l'ancien colonisateur et aussi chez les
anciens colonisés donc c'est démarche
viserait finalement voilà défaire à
déconstruire complètement chez tout le
monde même c'est même chez ceux qui ne
le demande pas finalement cette
perception ccc rémanence et rémanence de
du colonialisme et et là on à faire et
c'est très important à quelque chose de
10 juin du post colonialisme
on a affaire une démarche politique et
je crois que lorsque le ministre blanc
caire lorsque manuel valls
lorsque caroline fourest lorsque bernard
henri lévy qui ne sont pas des gens
d'extrême droite parlent d'islam au
gauchisme et ils l'ont fait savoir donc
ce n'est pas ma conviction profonde mais
en tout cas si on lit leurs textes leurs
craintes exprimées vis-à-vis de ces
mouvements plus politique au sein
d'universités et plus globalement comme
la ministre vidal l'a dit au sein de la
société en fait il n'ya pas il ya une
porosité naturel et c'est tant mieux
entre l'université le lieu des savoirs
et la société voilà les termes du débat
léotard a fuit alors sur les études des
colonials sur le décodeur le bleu des
colonialismes les termes du débat
quelques les pauses ça me bienvenu je ne
suis pas exactement d'accord avec ce
qu'il propose comme manière
d'appréhender les choses simplement
parce que sans entrer dans les détails
de regard du temps qui nous est imparti
mais la distinction première qu'on
pouvait faire simplement entre les
études postcoloniales et des études d
cologna s'est simplement considéré qu'
historiquement les chercheurs qui vont
se revendiquer des colonials et les
chercheurs qui ont plutôt se revendiquer
du post coloniale ne se situe pas au
même endroit les études postcoloniales
se réfère plutôt à la question des
indépendances des pays colonisés de
prendre plutôt encore du côté de
l'histoire contemporaine lab au
contraire les écoles et les études
pardon était colonial se situe plutôt du
côté d amérique du sud et prennent
plutôt comme date d'émergence de la
modernité de modernité violente l'année
1492 sans rentrer davantage dans les
détails on voit bien que la distinction
selon selon laquelle les études
postcoloniales serait toléré parce que
nos politiques mais les études des
colonials serait un toléré parce que nos
politiques parce que politiques en
particulier
ne tient pas de manière plus globale ici
et c'est quelque chose qui me semble
extrêmement important
le débat n'est pas scientifique ne nous
sommes pas ici dans un débat
scientifique où il serait question de
définir ce qui relèverait de la question
coloniale et postcoloniale des coloniale
et ses actes la question est
fondamentalement politique
le scientifique ce que nous faisons à
l'université quelles que soient les
branches disciplinaires dans lesquelles
nous nous inscrivons fait aussi partie
du politique
il n'y a pas de frontières absolument
hermétique entre ce qui relève du
politique et ce qui relèverait du
scientifique sauf qu'en tant que
scientifique nous sommes soumis à une
méthode et nous sommes surtout soumis au
jugement de nos pères ceux qui publient
des articles dans des revues par exemple
le savent très bien
le son d'un mental ici qui se posent à
nous c'est la question politique c'est
la question de l'émergence de plus en
plus un forte même si elle a été très
tenues ces dernières années et qu'elle
est dans une forme d'émergence à l'heure
actuelle de critiques assez forte du
caractère impérial que de revêtir l'état
français et notamment la question des
discriminations liées à la question
raciale qui continue à faire l'objet de
dénégation très fort quelle que soit la
discipline face à laquelle on se
retrouve mais bien évidemment que la
sociologie et visait plus que les autres
disciplines nous avons affaire à du
politique nous avons affaire à de la
critique à une critique d'état notamment
par rapport à la question du racisme
d'état du racisme se traversent les
institutions françaises et c'est bien ça
qui est visé et je voudrais simplement
rappeler un élément supplémentaire
il me semble que ce qui est visé est
éminemment politiques comme je le disais
mais ce qui est aussi éminemment
politique
tu n'es pas seulement ce qui est dit
c'est aussi qui le dit et on voit
émerger depuis un certain temps un
groupe très hétérogène de chercheurs qui
ont la particularité d'être et une femme
est originaire d'un milieu populaire et
une susceptibles d'être atteints par des
formes de racisme et qui occupent des
places importantes dans des universités
dans les laboratoires et qui ont accès à
des publications et il
que là aussi on a quelque chose qui
apparaît de manière très forte à savoir
le refus
une partie des descendants de
l'immigration postcoloniale porte un
regard critique et public sur l'état
français sur la france de manière
générale la question est vraiment
politique il faudrait pas qu'on s'engage
dans des débats trop scientifique parce
que ce serait là à mon avis une forme
d'impasse à la politique oui enfin je
vais avoir du mal à le distinguer de ce
qui vient d'être dit un jeu je suis
entièrement d'accord
ici il serait quand même assez difficile
de faire croire que les auteurs dits
postcoloniaux aurez droit de cité alors
que je suppose que frédéric vidal ne
fait pas une distinction aussi claires
que celles que évoqué sa vie biagioni
entre les uns et les autres il faudrait
faire croire que albert memmi aimé
césaire edouard glissant
frantz fanon edward saïd ne faisait pas
effectivement autre chose que de la
politique
weill il est évident que on ne peut pas
séparer la recherche scientifique et la
lutte pour l'émancipation
lorsqu'on est à un penseur de ce qu'a
été la colonisation et il est il est
clair que le refus que je trouve
extrêmement prégnant de faire un
inventaire de ce qu'a été l'aventuré
coloniale française de passer au crible
de la critique l'universalisme
assimilationniste la mission
civilisatrice de la france
tout ça est extrêmement préoccupant
c'est ce que j'ai voulu dire dès le
début et ce n'est pas par hasard et je
crois qu incontestablement il faut
examiner ces querelles dans la
perspective de l'élection présidentielle
et de la réduire et évidemment à
l'affrontement que nous avons déjà connu
il y aille à ce vin il ya quatre ans
donc je je je suis totalement d'accord
pour la distinction post colonialisme
des colonies israël des coloniaux ne
sont pas effectivement issu de la même
origine géographique qui sont plutôt
d'amérique latine pour la plupart
d'entre eux et ils sont on peut dire
peut-être au plus
adiko dans la mesure où il considère que
la modernité tout entière est à rejeter
c'est à dire que modernité colonialité
lier ils disent plutôt colonnes galite
éco colonialisme modernité et
colonialité vont de pair on ne peut pas
penser la modernité sans la colonialité
est comme ça a été rappelé excellemment
ça commence en 1992 au moment notamment
où les musulmans les juifs également
d'ailleurs sont expulsés d'espagne aux
trois lions n'a pas la même chronologie
on a mais on a des auteurs qui emprunte
tout de même des problématiques à ses
proches qu'il soit un peu séparés dans
le temps et il y a des différences et on
peut on peut d examiner et je crois de
la principale différence c'est que le
post colonialisme
même s'il fait des critiques à
l'universalisme reste fondamentalement
universaliste suffit de lire les textes
de fans ont même si parfois il ya
quelques ambiguïtés reste profondément
universaliste on peut effectivement
poser le débat est peut-être voir
quelques différences entre nous sur le
l'exigence universaliste dans le courant
des colonials il me semble qu'elle ait
quelque peu sacrifié
on le voit à partir de ce qu'on appelle
notamment l'épistémologie du point de
vue sur laquelle si vous le souhaitez
nous pourrons revenir mais effectivement
on y reviendra mais je donne la parole à
julian mais il nous reste juste une
minute quarante un mot et puis après on
fait une pause et on y revient
non mais je crois que tout ça témoigne
quand même d'une forme de panique morale
chez les élites politiques qui en or qui
ont beaucoup de mal à penser la fonction
critique des sciences sociales
d'une certaine façon et le président de
la république le disait l'année dernière
quand il attaque et les sciences
sociales déjà à l'époque en en
soulignant que au fond les
universitaires contribuerait à briser la
république en deux mois je crois qu'au
fond tous les travaux les différentes
traditions qui ont été évoqués à
l'instant quant à elle travaille sur les
questions raciales sur les
discriminations sur le continuum
coloniale ne brise pas la réplique du
temps de mail elle la met à nu d'une
certaine façon à mettre à nu les
contradictions de la société dans
laquelle on vit
en démontrant offrons toutes les formes
de domination et de discrimination qui
large qui la quitte à qui la traverse et
ce n'est pas fair 2010
anti sme d'une certaine façon que devrez
à cette fonction critique c'est
simplement de donner à voir
voilà le fait que les contrôles au
faciès sont systémiques à l'égard des
jeunes noirs ou arabes en france quand
lynette c'est une enquête comme
trajectoires et origines et montrent
l'ampleur des discriminations qui
traversent notre société il ya rien de
militants là dedans c'est la réalité
dans laquelle on vit et le problème
c'est que nos élites politiques refusent
de voir cette réalité là ce qui à mon
avis est dramatique c'est que cela
empêche derrière de de n'ouvrir les
politiques publiques c'est bien
qu'aujourd'hui les politiques publiques
sont nourris de connaissances tout à
fait biaisé et tronquée de la réalité et
c'est pas comme ça à mon sens que on
peut on peut avancer collectivement on
fait une pause en prose les bas juste
après
[Musique]
depuis des décennies il s'est imposé
comme la devise incontournable dans le
commerce international le dollar peut-il
être détrôné détrôner pas encore c'est
pas quelque chose d'à ce faire en un
jour ce que veut faire le chinois ce
qu'ils veulent des dollarisée l'asie
parce que le dollar à des folies qui
viennent de washington ce qu'on dit le
chinois ben si ça vous fait rien on va
régler nos problèmes de liquidité entre
asiatiques et on va se débarrasser des
états unis aujourd'hui les instruments
sont en place pour pouvoir se passer les
transactions en dollars
faut pas avoir fait de longues études
pour savoir si la masse monétaire double
aux états-unis et dé change pas en chine
va probablement dans les années qui
viennent la monnaie chinoise a monté
vis-à-vis de la monnaie américaine et
donc grosso modo il semble que s'il
était un jeune homme je suivrai le
conseil de parra l'est jeune homme
pour une fois je paraphrase ray monsieur
macron c'est en marche
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde je suis
répond en appartement on est énervé on a
le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent majoritaire mâcon et passe un
tour de tracteur avec nous puis vraie
campagne il faut savoir c'est qu'une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt td quoi un peu plus
aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
nous prenons ce débat sur l'islam au
gauchisme ou ce que l'on entend par
islam au gauchisme avec sami bien sony
avec kaoutar harchi à la poly carré
julien teil pain et à la folie car vous
avez parlé vous avez prononcé le mot
universalisme c'est effectivement le mot
qui fâche général canton ce que l'on
reproche aux études des colonials hand
et on peut en sus de de parler d'un de
racisme d'état de de privilèges blanc
mais ce serait de d'avoir oublié
l'universalisme et de remettre au fond
la race au coeur du débat
qu'en pensez vous il faut dire que les
unes des colonials c'est un ensemble
extrêmement hétérogène dans lesquels
beaucoup d'auteurs ne reconnaîtrait pas
la pertinence de ce que je viens de dire
l'universalisme me semble parfois en
péril lorsque on cherche à rétablir
effectivement l'importance des origines
des racines des traditions moi vous
savez ce qui me caractérise
essentiellement c'est d'être un as
cosmopolite au sens philosophique du
terme bien évidemment pas au sens du
voyageur de celui qui connaîtra un grand
nombre de pays et entendent cosmopolite
je me méfie beaucoup des racines et il
me semble que il ya eu quelques de
tendance si vous voulez chez quelques
penseurs des coloniaux a exalté 7 ses
origines et en faire une fierté moi je
crois que c'est par hasard que nous
sommes ce que nous sommes et
l'exaltation des fierté d'appartenance
originel ça ça me paraît relativement
dangereux maintenant ce n'est pas chez
tous les auteurs que l'on retrouve ce
travers voilà je je je crois qu'il faut
faire la part des choses
on confond souvent en france un des
coloniaux et indigéniste en oubliant
d'ailleurs que les indigéniste ce sont
souvent des gens de gauche
qui ont voulu lutter pour la liberté des
indigènes à l'époque où il subissait les
colonisations
mais aujourd'hui la ligier nisme ça
paraît être simplement résumé dans le
parti des indigènes de la république et
par sa presse aux makes présidente
houria bouteldja qui incontestablement
n'a pas rendu service à la cause et
colonial kaoutar harchi contrebande de
la cause des colonials pour cité
l'expression d'alain pollica c'est comme
si on opposait martin luther king qui
lui étaient universaliste et balkanique
ce qui ne l'aurait pas été où les black
panthers coeuret exalté une fierté
identitaire traite en plus à la défendre
les armes à la main et c'est ce qui a
l'air d'inquiéter un certain nombre de
gens y eut surtout et y compris parmi
nos dirigeants qu'en pensez vous je
pense que c'est extrêmement compliqué
parce que comme le disait à
l'implication des traditions
intellectuelles qui est extrêmement ont
diverses se réunissent à certains
endroits et puis qu'il ya d'autres
endroits
ces douaniers décident de diverger pour
porter des projets des projets
différents sur la question de
l'universalisme
encore une fois je vais peut être une
question extrêmement complexe mais je
pense que néanmoins on peut aussi
essayer de considérer que s'il ya une
critique de l'universalisme et c'est
aussi une critique d'un certain
universaliste qui en réalité se
présentent aussi quand même beaucoup
comme une forme de particularités
occidental qui a été imposé à l'ensemble
de la terre entière est imposé sous la
forme de la violence sous la forme d'un
potentiel mise à bord ou en tout cas
mise en danger physique des aides
individuelles celles à l'histoire
coloniale dans tout dans toute son
ampleur par rapport à cette question de
l'universalisme dont il y a ainsi une
tentative du côté de ces études
postcoloniales des colonials de replacer
les traditions de replacer les
différentes coutumes de replacer les
expériences subjectives dans une
centralité qui serait celle des
individus qui sont concernés c'est pour
ça que par rapport à la question de
l'universalisme je ne serais pas aussi
inquiète que alain bolhy car encore une
fois je répète il faudrait précisément
savoir de quel point à ce que l'on parle
mais je pense qu'il est extrêmement
important de bien avoir à l'esprit que
les différentes tentatives intellectuels
dont nous parlons ici sont des
tentatives qui ont pris aussi des
chemins extrêmement différents la poésie
lapetina création la question de la mise
en forme théâtrale pouvoir susciter des
formes de traditions anciennes tout ça
fait partie du débat est ce qui fait
partie du débat de manière extrêmement
forte
c'est la volonté de décentrer des formes
de subjectivité dominante qui écrase des
subjectivités subalternes et qui n'ont
est par exemple pas accès à l'espace
public et qui n'ont pas la possibilité
de se vivre comme étant elle-même
universel comme étant elle même une
totalité
donc on retrouve malgré tout dans cette
tension entre universalisme et
particularismes
la tension très forte qui lie ce qui
serait le l'identitaire et ceux qui
seraient de nature elle est évidemment
qu'à partir de ce moment là des
populations vont se mettre en branle
pour tenter de légitimer leur existence
et leur présence au sein des nations
dominantes et ça fait partie d'une
certaine manière de la marche de
l'histoire que de tenter d'aller
toujours vers un peu plus d'émancipation
politique et d'un peu plus de progrès je
pense que la grande violence ici qui est
qui et qui est à l'oeuvre c'est celle
évidemment qui tente de mettre à mal
l'idée selon laquelle nous serions tous
égaux or d'un point de vue social les
inégalités sont extrêmement fortes que
l'on se situe dans le nord globale ou
qu'on se situe du côté du sud
l'emprise des femmes occidentales de vie
sont extrêmement puissante
c'est aussi une critique très forte de
la blanche cité c'est aussi une critique
très forte des processus de
racialisation qui participent à séparer
la société en deux entre des
institutions oppressante et des
populations des groupes qui sont
oppressés et qui aimerait mettre fin à
l'oppression qu'ils subissent pas les
bienvenus alors je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs
question extrêmement intéressante dans
les propos de un peu l'écart et de
madame archi je vais rentrer t2 d'une
part si je reprends les propos de madame
archi il est question de subjectivité et
de la valorisation des expériences
subjectives savoir que
méthodologiquement alors sans entrer
puisque mais meco débattant ne l'ont pas
fait je le ferai pas non plus dans des
détails trop compliqué ou trop
académique soit il que d'un point de vue
méthodologique en fait cesser ces
disciplines
ces champs de recherche adopte une
méthodologie très phénoménologique très
subjectiviste c'est-à-dire qu'ils
ramènent qui forment des concepts elle
est très conceptuel liste est très
nominative et c'est à dire que ces modes
de pensée qu'on reçoit beaucoup de
concepts et ensuite les mettre à
l'épreuve de l'expérience individuelle
et et c'est là qu'on peut avoir une
ligne de fracture entre deux manières
d'interpréter cela sauvera considérer
que ça c'est une manière d'actualiser la
pensée la démarche critique et c'est la
ligne qui est qui est défendue je crois
par madame archi si je j'entends bien
ses propos et puis je les ya lui et
c'est effectivement la ligne qui est
défendue par une grande partie des
penseurs de la mouvance des colonials ou
du mouvement des colonials nous les
colonialistes et ensuite il ya une une
autre réaction possible qui est celle de
dire en fait on ne tente de remplacement
de substitution voire de déconstruction
du rationalisme un rationalisme qui a
fait ses preuves qui personne ne dit ou
alors en tout cas ce n'est pas mon
propos que c'est la seule manière de
mettre à l'épreuve les questions
sociales sociétales qui ont été évoqués
précédemment personne ne dit cela et
c'est encore une fois pas mon propos
simplement on peut aussi réaffirmé sans
dire que c'est un instrument de
domination sans dire que c'est un
instrument d'oppression simplement
l'amour du logos l'amour de la
rationalité qui nous a été donnée confié
engage par par la pensée antique et qui
a cheminé au travers effectivement de
l'occident est en fait je pense que
cette notion subjective t elle et c'est
un point d'ancrage 1.2
divergence assez important au sein de
l'université et et il faut bien le
comprendre
le deuxième élément très rapidement mais
encore une fois je balaye le sujet c'est
celui de l'universalisme
effectivement ce qui est reproché la
crainte des personnes que j'ai cités
c'est à dire qu on a commencé on a
ouvert ce débat en disant que estime
hugo cie ce matin terme d'extrême droite
mais ce que je sache certes il a pu être
adoubé par des personnes de 5 droite
mais chacun a le droit de l'adouber ce
qu'il le souhaite ça n'en fait pas ça
n'implique pas pour celui qui a été
adoubé qu'il soit complice il n'a pas
choisi qu'il a doublé et on voit des
personnalités de la gauche républicaine
on voit au sein des les filles et on a
eu un sondage récent qui montre que la
majeure partie de la gauche aujourd'hui
se pose la question de cette question
alors encore une fois attention au terme
de sa main gauche et se met en tout cas
de paix une création un manque d'idées
qui sont des revendications 80 et c'est
la définition que j'en donne et je
comprends que d'autres puissent
considérer que le terme est galvaudé
qu'il faut l'entendre selon d'autres ex
acception ma conviction profonde c'est
que un bernard-henri lévy une frédéric
vidal ont à peu près la même conception
qui est celle de dire attention nous
avons l'impression qu'une frange
minoritaire mais vous savez bien que les
révolutions toujours été faits par des
minorités agissantes une frange
minoritaire veut imposer un dogme veut
imposer une politique plus radical alain
policard le disais ce n'est pas
l'intégralité des penseurs de du des
colonialismes mais simplement ce sont
les plus agissants et que ceux là
peuvent induire des comportements
difficiles et attentatoire à la liberté
parfois de penser parfois d'enseignés
d'enseigner ou en tout cas disposer
disposer du dudu du canon des ressources
et des systèmes de pensée dont
l'université dispose est
traditionnellement voilà donc cette
question elle est essentielle et je
pense que c'est là le terme du débat
autour de la question de l'islamo
gauchisme iliad alpin je ne peux que
m'inscrire en faux avec ce qu'il a
dédiée notamment l'idée qu'ils auraient
une volonté d'imposer un un dogme au
fond aux débats au débat scientifique
l'essentiel des travaux dont on parle en
fait des approches postcoloniale des
colonials et études raciale aujourd'hui
en ce sens c'est des approches
empiriques en réalité ne cherche pas à
imposer des concepts grille de lecture
non messieurs travaux historiques
anthropologiques sociologiques qui
simplement un avoir des réels et qui
trop longtemps visibiliser y compris par
les sciences sociales
donc à moi je crois pas du tout les
sciences sociales en fasse trop veulent
imposer tout simplement à voir et qui
jusqu'àlors il a été bien long bien
souvent bien souvent mis sous le tapis
par ailleurs sous ces questions
d'identité en fait une demande de part
en part et être inscrits à cette
exaltation des racines cette fierté
identitaire dont entendons parler à la
police qu'un bon moi je jouais pas
beaucoup de gens en sciences sociales au
sein de l'université française qui
véritablement je serai sûr sauvage ce
champ là mais si on revient à l'espace
politique et au chant des mouvements
sociaux
je ne crois pas non plus c'est à dire
que on accuse bien souvent les uns et
les mouvements antiracistes par exemple
d'être dans la des revendications
identitaires si on s'attache précisément
à leurs revendications
fouille assez peu d'enjeu identitaire
qui sont bien avancés ces mouvements là
sinon dans ce comité à damas si on pense
au même à la brigade anti négrophobie
whaou à de nombreux collectifs comme le
ccis par exemple 10 ou récemment leurs
enjeux c'est pas un enjeu de
reconnaissance d'une identité c'est
d'abord un enjeu d'égalité en réel et
bien souvent il ya une sorte de
disqualification de ses revendications
d'égalité en leur plaque en une volonté
d' identitaire qui peuvent être présents
de façon sous jacente il ya toujours une
volonté de retourner le stigmate face à
des groupes qui ont été historiquement
minorés néanmoins c'est d'abord des
mobilisations égalitaire et en ce sens
pour retomber sur la question de
l'universalisme ci à une critique de
l'universalisme abstrait je ne crois pas
du tout que ces mobilisations la soie en
tant que tel en ti universaliste
puisqu'elle s'inscrit précisément dans
ce paradigme de la lutte pour l'égalité
est reproché également l'islamo
gauchisme entre guillemets l université
ce serait de pratiquer au fond la
censure de pratiquer la cancel culture
au fond d'être intolérant de ne pas
accepter le débat et
la police car sur ce sujet c'était pas
l'expérience que j'en ai je dialogue
souvent avec des gens avec lesquels j'ai
quelques nuances à julien talpin vient
d'exprimer quelques nuances avec mon
point de vue je je les connaissais mais
je ne crois pas du tout que i lié à
l'université la moindre tentative
d'empêcher ceux qui ne pensent pas comme
les des coloniaux que le suppose
frédéric vidal de s'exprimer qu'on fasse
une étude concernant les thèses qui sont
menées sur ces sujets là peuvent être
effectivement extrêmement instructif
je crois que la parole a tendance à se
libérer que les souffrances passées
peuvent effectivement trouvé dans des
travaux universitaires les moyens d'être
théorisé c'est une excellente chose
alors bon revenir avec la question
universalisme là où peut-être je me
distingue 10 2 mai deux interlocuteurs
de ce soir c'est que tout de même on ne
peut pas passer sous silence
l'idée que la parole des racisées aurait
un privilège dans l'expression de la
souffrance
c'est ça qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure
en parlant d'épistémologie du point de
vue la sphère des suppliante d'eschyle
par exemple en fait ils paradigmatique
qui consiste à empêcher de
représentation d'un metteur en scène qui
a une longue expérience de la tragédie
grecque qui l'a représenté en afrique et
qui a utilisé des masques qu'il avait à
mon sens pas grand chose à voir avec le
black fait ce qui est incontestablement
une pratique raciste ça ça me semble
être tout de même à un moment
d'intolérance ailleurs il faudrait que
nous reparlions peut-être de ce qu'est
vraiment la tolérance parce que je crois
que chez les penseurs républicains dont
a parlé
sami biasini précisément la tolérance
n'est pas comprise et elle est au
contraire considéré comme s'opposant au
modèle laïque à la française hier
s'opposant à l'universalisme
simulateur universalisme de surplomb je
préfère dire de surplomb plutôt caps
très parce qu'il ya toujours une
abstraction universalisme l'homme et
considérait effectivement comme une
abstraction universalisme surplomb qui
reposerait donc effectivement un modèle
au reste du monde et à cet universalisme
là on peut préférer on doit préférer un
universalisme réitératif comme le disait
ricoeur l'universalisme pluriel comme
disait pierre astaire on peut utiliser
beaucoup de terre - universalisme
latéral comme disait maurice merleau
ponty
donc moi je suis effectivement très
attachés à cette exigence universaliste
et je crois que tout de même même si je
n'ai pas convaincu julien talpin sur
cette question là il y à me semble-t-il
des théorisations qui consiste au fond à
dire l'universalisme
il a commis trop on a commis trop de
crimes en son nom eh bien il faut s'en
émanciper il me paraît ça ne paraît plus
d'erreurs ça me bienvenu sur sur cette
intolérance que l'on reproche justement
août nom du des colonialismes à travers
un certain nombre de manifestations la
sphère déchu pliante d'eschyle avait
fait les grands titres
votre point de vue alors une premier
lieu sonnerait a finalement à signifier
qu'on s'écarte un peu du débat j'ai le
titre en bon dos on parle de dé
colonialisme et le sujet est passionnant
j'ai écrit dessus je m'y intéresse
je suis ravi de débattre avec les
personnes qui connaissent le sujet qui
ont leur point de vue au départ la
démission du slam au gauchisme je vais
rappeler la définition et j'ai repris le
texte de l'ifop dans son sondage
s'adressant à la population c'est à dire
donc à des individus qui sont moins
renseignés que les interlocuteurs
ici autour de cette table depuis
quelques mois le terme entre entre
guillemets l'islamo gauchisme est
particulièrement utilisé dans des débats
politiques
actuellement ce mot est utilisé pour
qualifier des intellectuels des
personnalités ou des partis politiques
située à gauche ou à l'extrême gauche
qui minimiserait la menace représentée
par l'islamisme radical dans notre pays
ou refuseraient de dénoncer at islamisme
radical
par souci de ne pas stigmatiser les
stigmatiser les musulmans ici considérée
comme une minorité opprimée
ça c'est la définition qu'en a donnée
l'ifop haut à laquelle on adhère à ou
pas d'ailleurs et c'est intéressant
simplement de voir ici n'est nullement
question de post colonialisme des
colonialismes peut-être qu on dérive un
peu mais je suis ravi de discuter de ce
sujet là la question et elle est très
bonne celle de la tolérance amis je vous
interromps jussie en dérive
c'est qu'en fait je n'ai remis sur le
terrain universitaire mais vous avez
tout à fait raison
la plupart du temps même si les études
des colonials sont particulièrement
stigmatisés par les nos dirigeants
politiques
vous avez raison c'est à peu près dans
une définition comme celle que veut qu'à
donner l'ifop que l'entente de la
plupart des dirigeants politiques qui
s'en prennent à tort ou à raison à
l'islam ou l'office et et je je je
vraiment je voudrais pas aller au-delà
de ce cas des alliés sûrs d'être je suis
pas là pour la défendre du tout mais
j'ai essayé d'écouter avec beaucoup de
conscience ces propos et a priori c'est
ce qu'elle essaye de dire donc on en
revient maintenant à la question
effectivement de la tolérance à
l'université je pense que la question de
l'intolérance c'est ça a été celle qui a
constitué le point pivot de 2 de ses
interrogations de l'interrogation selon
laquelle il pourrait se passer quelque
chose dans l'université que l'université
par endroits et personne je crois nous
dit en tout cas je vous laisserai
compléter si mes lectures on était
lacunaire mais personne ne dit que tout
linéaire steak gangréné mais qu'une
partie de l'université certains centres
certaines universités très syndicalisés
prêt syndiqué certains centres de
recherche spécialisés ou avec des
personnes qui se revendique d'une
militance dur ou d'un conte ans avec une
militance dur que cette portion de
l'université puisse effectivement skier
dans ce bel édifice l'intolérance
l'incapacité à écouter autrui à
développer une pensée contradictoires
dans le respect de la démarche
scientifique
voilà mon sens les vrais termes du débat
fusse-t-il ensuite polarisé autour des
questions et c'est vrai de genre de race
qui sont des champs de recherche plus
récents qui ont comme je l'expliqué
cette force de la subjectivité qui la
disent aussi
effectivement cette importance du point
de vue qui les disent aussi des champs
de recherche traditionnels jeux logos
classique j'ai envie de dire et donc qui
perturbe
mais au départ et un dernier point
peut-être on a beaucoup galvauder les
propos de encore une fois mais je m'en
tiens vertement un stricte vérité des
faits je n'aimais pas de point de vue
lorsqu'on reprend les propos de la
ministre vidal dès le début elle ne
parle pas d'en quête elle ne dis pas
d'ailleurs que l'objet de l'enquète en
tant que tel c'est la pensée islamo
gauchiste mais simplement elle parle du
fait politique dans l'université et elle
demande une étude et c'est pour cela
d'ailleurs qu'elle confie assez
maladroitement au cnrs qui finalement
d'après les dernières informations dont
on dispose se trouve disposé à faire une
étude dans le cadre de ses prérogatives
usuelles simplement il faut bien
comprendre ce dont il s'agit c'est à
dire je crois que mon mail tout et c'est
la grande difficulté de ce débat et
c'est pour cela que nous n'arrivons pas
à nous entendre et c'est pour cela et
c'est pour cela que j'ai tenu à ouvrir
mon propos par cette grande confusion
qu'il existe autour d'un débat qui peut
très sincèrement nous réunir je pense
que ici toutes les personnes sont
attachées à la liberté de pensée quelle
que soit la méthode à la liberté à la
rigueur scientifique et aujourd'hui
cette rigueur cette liberté de france et
peut être menacée la sphère de ce client
est un exemple mais on a vu le cas de
mohamed sifaoui qui n'a pas pu venir
donner un séminaire sous la pression de
certains syndicats et qui a été tout de
suite taxés d'islamophobie parce qu'il
traitait de la question de l'islamisme
ce genre de situation et elles sont
nombreuses a effectivement doivent nous
interpeller et doivent nous conduire à
penser le bien fondé ou non de ce type
d'explications de l'université qui est
normalement un lieu d'ouverture un lieu
d'acceptation de tous les savoirs toutes
les connaissances et toutes les
compétences et ou tard archi on écoute
on
mon interlocuteur je suis un peu je suis
un peu la télé puisque si je reprends
les critères qui ont guidé les siens
on va essayer de nous expliquer de
convaincre même peut-être qu'il
existerait une vente de menaces à
l'université les critères étaient des
critères de spécialisation descente qui
serait spécialisé on espère qu'ils sont
spécialisés des centres ou des personnes
travailleraient en étant syndiqués et
les corps des personnes travailleraient
en et en ayant une forme de militantisme
encore une fois je reviens à ce que l'on
disait auparavant mais c'est simple
critère si je suis la réflexion de mon
interlocuteur ils jalonnent les
accompagnent lys 3 ou universitaires
depuis l'apparition des disciplines ce
qui me semble être derrière cette
explication et qui dit son nom mais sans
véritablement l'assumer pleinement se
cachant après derrière les propos de la
ministre est derrière un point de vue
qui serait qui serait neutre alors qu'en
vérité le départ il ne l'est pas du tout
c'est l'idée encore une fois qu'il y
aurait finalement des minorités qui au
sein de la société française ferait
peser un danger sur la pérennité de
cette de cette dernière alors ça ça
s'appelle de manière très claire et on
peut aussi citer des définitions à n'en
plus finir
mais ça ça s'appelle typiquement des
formes de croyance en la conspiration
la théorie conspirationniste elle
transpire absolument des propos de la de
la ministre la théorie conspirationniste
elle transpire et aussi des propos d'
emmanuel macron aux mureaux comme l a
transpiré depuis quelques temps et
pendant plus de 200 heures à l'assemblée
nationale lorsque la loi sur les
séparatismes a été a été discuté donc
encore une fois ce sont des minorités en
particulier des groupes en particulier
pour être très clair ce sont des groupes
racisés qu'ils font à chaque fois
l'objet de tentative d'effacement de
tentatives de disqualification de
l'espace public et de tentatives de
disqualification des espaces de pouvoir
tels que l'université peut être un
espace de pouvoir donc c'est pour ça que
face à cette théorie conspirationniste
c'est important de souligner à chaque
fois à quel point il
à des perceptions nationalistes des
perceptions très concentré et des
perceptions grassi amusante qui sont qui
sont à l'heure qu'ils sont profondément
injuste puisque elles viennent jeter le
discrédit sur des groupes profondément
l'hétérogène qui travaillent de manière
extrêmement diverses mais qui travaille
toujours encore une fois en se
soumettant au cadre méthodologique de
l'université donc on voit bien ici à
quel poids en mobilisant une sorte de
méconnaissance d'ignorance volontaire de
ce qu'est véritable université on
rejette à nouveau une partie à une
partie des chercheurs et une partie de
leurs recherches vers l'idée que cela
représenterait finalement le ventre mou
de l'islamisme et la fin probable de la
société voire de l'art de la deûle
empire français tel qu'il se présente
encore sous nos yeux parfum donc il me
semble extrêmement important d'être
d'être pressé baisse par rapport à ce
type de discours qui ne sont absolument
étayée par aucun élément empirique
je rappelle une anecdote et qu'un
événement ne veut pas faire l'objet
peuvent être tenues comme comme argument
si on revient à ce qu'il s'est passé
dans les théâtres à ce qui s'est passé
dans les annulations de conférence cela
relève de politique de boycott cela
relève de pratiques militantes de
groupes qui défendent des intérêts
politiques qu'ils soient dès lors qu'on
soit d'accord qu'on ne soit pas d'accord
avec ces pratiques à ces pratiques là
elle existe de tout temps mais
lorsqu'elles sont incarnés par un type
particulier d'individus et de groupes
elles font l'objet d'une criminalisation
et d'une criminalisation évidemment
racistes alors ils n'auraient explique
une minute 30 secondes chacun alain
policard et julien tape là julien
oui mais je crois que c'est tout un
délire sur la grande scène culture
aujourd'hui à l'université qui est
cliquée qui n'existent pas en réalité on
débat voyez moi dans mon laboratoire g
stephan peau qui n'est pas exactement
sur les mêmes positions que pointent les
minères bien qu'on pourra échanger sur
nos points de vue et donc regarder
comment ils effectivement ça se passe la
diversité ci se rendre compte que les
questions dont on a parlé ce square des
travaux sur les questions raciales
demeure extrêmement minoritaire et sont
loin de constituer la majorité des
recherches en sciences sociales c'est
pas quelque chose de bankable
aujourd'hui comme on l'entend parfois de
travailler cette question est au
contraire c'est parfois coûteux il ya
peu de financements de recherche ya peu
de postes et donc il faut il faut
regarder ça à mon avis beaucoup plu à
beaucoup plus pas de man et dernier -
peut-être quand bien même il n'y a pas
de camps de cette culture à l'université
moi je ne vois pas du tout cela dans ma
pratique quotidienne je crois que c'est
quand même important aussi de se dire
qu'il peut être intéressant de laisser
un peu de place à des points de vue qui
ont été longtemps minorisées où un
physique à l'université - en tant qu
homme blanc pas que je laisse un peu de
place à des collègues femmes que je
laisse de la place à des collègues
racisées pour faire part de leur
expérience qu'elle puisse avoir aussi
leur mot à dire au sein de l'université
française ça me semble sain et en tant
que telle à laisser un peu plus de place
je ne me sens pas annulée elle il est
dans ma liberté d'expression derniers
mots à la poly car très vite parce qu'on
a déjà dépassé
d'accord je vais dire rapidement que
c'est totalement d'accord avec les idées
qui viennent de s'être exprimée
notamment l'idée de conspiration en
affaire je crois à une conspiration et
je regrette que ça libya's honni et
paraît de gangrène parce qu'il est
supposé effectivement que l'ia à
l'oeuvre dans l'université a processus
qui vise à restreindre la liberté de
recherche ce qui évidemment est
totalement faux les concepts sont là
pour désigner des choses et des choses
réelles ou trouve des mots qu'on n'avait
pas jusqu'à présent utilisé comme
racisées qui me semblent désigner une
réalité près tout à fait prêts précise
de même que le mot féminicide et
d'instauration récente et pourtant il
désigne bien des faits je crois que les
mots nouveaux les concepts nouveaux
d'eysines des réalités tout à fait
importante est la principale de ces
réalité c'est que
il ya eu les injustices épistémique il
s'agit de réparer
je vous remercie tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]